hi everyone I'm Victor thanks for having
us here thanks s of html5 for arranging
this wonderful meet up I work for gue
technologies based in Stockholm Sweden
and with me today as Peter said is
another Peter from kissing based here in
California and as a colleague of mine
put it WebGL is very good at solving a
very specific computer science problem
of today and that problem is to get the
highest amount of likes per line of code
the measurement to keep track of the
next two years will be LPL the likes per
line and we've seen as we've seen in the
previous talks that for example chrome
experiments collecting a lot of really
cool hacks of WebGL wizardry and WebGL
WebGL examples from from people that
know this really well but the question
now is how do we get this into more
hands how do we get WebGL into the hands
of all the creators that are out there
and this of course can be graphics
wizards and game developers and hackers
but it can also be artists T architects
teachers advertising advertisers
interface designers and so on how do we
give them the power of WebGL and the
answer to that question is we build
pipelines and we design work flows
because not everyone not everyone dreams
about spending all their fried and
nights with shader debugging I know it's
really hard to imagine those people
exist but they do so the first step as
we've already seen also is to get a 3d
engine going it takes care of all the
low-level WebGL stuff that we don't want
to do every time it gives us a nice API
to play with and one thing that I think
is very important when we do this is
that we try to use open web standards as
much as possible in this case it means
nothing but javascript HTML 5 and of
course WebGL because what happens then
is that a lot of people know JavaScript
and suddenly they have now had tools to
also kind of know 3d and it also means
that you don't have any plugins or in
downloads necessary to share your work
later so i want to show you this show
you some more demos so that's kind of
why we're here right so this first demo
can show you that not only can you
render cool 3d stuff you can also
integrate other things and it's like for
example video like in this case once you
decide to use all these open standards
the other demo I want to show is this
one is something that we've seen so many
sliders I need more resolution Peter
where's the resolution oh well then oh
now we see the slider and I can click
that one sorry about that there we go
this is a demo of a pretty much a
full-fledged flight simulator of a
really old Swedish fighter plane those
exist actually it's a thing I did not
make that up it's this is screencast is
running in is recorded in chrome and
it's something that we've have developed
internally while we are a gue are
building our go engine because it turns
out it's not easy to build a pipeline
and it's really hard to define a
workflow and you need people to kind of
tell you how they want it to be done so
this is what can be done of course and
it's really useful to have people in
house to do that kind of stuff that so
so that's that's great now if we have we
have a couple of different 3d 3d engines
and open web standards that we can use
but what do we do about the people that
don't don't want to code or don't know
how to code well the answer is again we
build a pipeline we build more things we
build a pipeline that's that can handle
things so if you have a model of a
really old Swedish fighter plane and you
want to get this online you need a way
to do that and you need a way to do
things with visually without necessarily
writing code code all the time to move
things around and then of course you
want to be able to share it with as many
power users as possible to get as many
likes as possible that's the whole point
so I'd like to show you a tool that that
does is try to solve part of this puzzle
and this tool will be
all goo create looks like this and this
part here to the right is the the the 3d
canvas where the 3d engine will put all
the other stuff and render that the
interface that you can see to the left
here is built using a very very very
large amount of angular and the behind
all this there's a Python back-end
running and the backend takes care of
exporting and importing models into a
format that the engine understands but
it also feels the very important part of
managing users and projects because in a
pipeline of course you want to play you
want a place to to do your things you
want one place to to to store all your
work so the way this works is say that
you have a a 3d model that's someone
built in this case and save it in an
colada kind of large large FBX file
format and what you can do here you see
simply if we can get all the windows to
see at the same time you can drag and
drop this onto the canvas and once the
the backend has converted this to a
model a sorry a format that the engine
understands we can start to interact
with it so there we go now we have this
3d model here and I can start start
interacting with it looks kind of creepy
right now but luckily the designers
thought of that and and put some put
some materials and textures on through
this so clothing for example what we can
do here now is do some more more
dragging dropping because I happen to
have textures in a standard PNG format
here so this was the clothing so let's
just actually let's do see if we can see
what happens here drag and drag and drop
that onto onto the model and then we can
do the same thing for for the hair there
we go and for the skin as well
there we go and that looks a little
better right and this interface lets us
interact with the with it and add things
like sounds and cameras and lights and
so on and this this model happens to
have an animation so if a pets play here
you can we can we can watch it and see
it in real time without writing any code
so let's try to a delight for example
and see what happens add light here and
we can start moving that around set some
parameters and see the scene change in
real time fully interactively it's all
in the browser it's not using any
plugins or any downloads like that and
let's go to my favorite panel and it's
put the post effects panel it's very
good for likes very good of likes so if
we want to add some glow to this okay
that's a bit much maybe it'll turn it
down a little bit or some some grain we
can add some movie big netting etc etc
you get the point and once we're done
with the scene out thanks to thanks to
that we have all these awesome web
standards to play with we can share our
work very easily by just basically
clicking about and bundling everything
up together including the engine and the
data format and pushed his turret
website and now if you have a decent
WebGL WebGL compatible browser on your
tablet or your phone or your computer on
your refrigerator or your washing
machine you can surf into this to this
website and look at this right now
actually I'll give you a tiny URL
version of this in a minute and of
course if you want a code you can do
that as well you can export this into a
JavaScript template and add your your
own code and then keep working on that
because we like to code right now so if
you want to try that try this out you
can you can do that you can go to that
tiny URL and you'll see the same link or
you can sign up for the beta it's it's
free right now if you want to try the
tool up so what happens now what's next
we have now we have all these things I
can take my Swedish fighter jet model
and put it on the Internet but we need
to think about what
in the future and I want to talk a
little bit about the funnel it's about
it's a kind of a pipeline right you take
a lot of input and you get a very
defined one kind of output so here's my
invention it's the double funnel
probably the worst invention ever made
if you would ever use it in real life
it's really hard to get venture capital
for it but if you want to talk later we
can do that but it illustrates the point
here we want to take a wide array of
inputs from different people and
different formats for different purposes
use the tools that we have and then push
it out to their different distribution
channels cooperation ways we want to
push this to different games two apps
two programs whatever you name it so the
double fungal it's the future promise
and then one time again of course we're
like demos I want to show you a little
bit more complete product built on built
on this new engine it's the same guy
that we saw that we saw earlier and this
one I can I can make him roll round here
by pressing the standard standard keep
keyboard control i can turn him around
and so forth it's all done interactively
in real time and I mean a mouse and
keyboard is fine but if we want to kick
it up a few notches Peter what do we do
then
microphone yes excellent thank you great
Thank You Vicker this is awesome so what
we have seen is that you can add extra
layers and tooling on top of WebGL and
by doing so you can make it accessible
to those who are not necessarily coding
so what I wanted to discuss a little bit
is how we can use related html5
technologies to improve the WebGL
experience specifically the area that we
are focusing on and I've been focusing
on in the last couple of years is real
time web communications and how you can
improve this experience so what I've
done here is I pulled up a remote
control on my browser the remote control
on my phone is running in Safari without
having installed anything I have a URL
that I want to and by simply tapping the
buttons here on my phone I am sending
messages to the application that's
running here on the on the desktop so
what is happening here behind the scene
my phone is on the AT&T LTE network and
it has a means to send very low latency
very small messages to my pc over here
so let's take a very quick look at how
we can achieve this kind of experience
let me do a little bit of dancing here
so I have my desktop app pulled up that
is a web browser on the top and on the
bottom we see my Safari browser both of
these html5 apps are connecting to a
WebSocket server the WebSocket server
has the ability to receive and send
messages so very much like thank you
very much like in the world of HTTP you
do need a WebSocket server for WebSocket
communication the fundamental difference
between the rest based world and the
WebSocket based world is that you have
the ability to keep this connection open
between your client and the server and
send these messages with extreme low
overhead back and forth between between
the server so my desktop application is
not sitting there and polling the server
is there a new message for me is there a
new message for me it's just sitting
there
and whenever I press a button here on my
phone the WebSocket server passes that
message to the application and we close
this and it allows us to navigate on the
screen so a few words about this
communication technique originally it
was designed to bring the same power to
web applications that we have in the
world of any connected application in
the TCP world so now you can say that
whatever app there is out there whenever
whatever connected app is out there in
the world of TCP now we can do that over
the web and this gives us an incredible
power to improve our web GL and non
WebGL applications so we have this
permanent connection and allows us to
build these event-driven applications
which is a major shift from having rest
oriented request-response kind of
applications where the client is
requesting information from the server
now you have the ability to send these
messages freely back and forth when
you're building a network application
you are not going against a low-level
network API or a protocol you are
building an email application right chat
application there's a good chance that
you're using something like I'm a poor
smtp for email or XMPP jabber for your
email client WebSocket as the standard
was designed to support these higher
level richer protocols so in our case
you can build very easy pops of
experiences pops of AP is that allow you
to build these apps very quickly and
very easily not only that WebSocket was
not designed to be there exclusively for
web browsers it was designed to be
agnostic to the client so you can build
native mobile applications you can build
Android iOS applications natively not
only that you can build desktop
applications you can have a.net a flash
or a java application that can have this
kind of real-time communication all over
going all over the web so again remember
i had a browser-based app running here
in my phone I was connecting to the
network over LTE I press the button here
and that message sent was sent to the
WebSocket server and it
back here to my laptop that WebSocket
server that I was communicating with is
in the east coast of the US 3,000 miles
away from here so it had to cross the
continent back and forth to get this
data here across ok now I wanted to show
an example how this can be elevated even
further everybody brought their awesome
3d designs and often awesome 3d models
and I decided to bring mine so here i
have my 3d model just look at the
textures here look at the reflections on
the on the design it's pretty impressive
so what is this we went out to toys r us
and we bought a radio-controlled truck
and after driving it around a little bit
in the office we said that maybe we can
do it better so we ripped out all the
radio control functionality and we glued
a credit card sized little computer onto
the back of the truck and what this does
is it has USB ports you can attach a
little Wi-Fi card it has an Ethernet
port it has an SD card that you can put
you can put the operating system on but
most importantly it has the ability to
control external electronics it has a
notion of a general-purpose input/output
port that allows you to control let's
say a car you can kind of drive it
around in our case we have three pairs
of these adapters and I'm going to
attempt to show that to you in a minute
now I could drive it around the same way
I was trying to control or I was
controlling the leap boy on the screen
or the the / boy on the screen but my
favorite way of showing this kind of
demonstration is having somebody very
far away maybe continents away skyped in
and have that person control the truck
now we have some network limitations
here
and we couldn't achieve this orca
couldn't quite do this this set of this
networking but I brought the experience
to you so I'm kind of doing these
acrobatic tricks without the net
underneath me so we'll try to do this so
what is going to happen is I will bring
up a page and in this page we are going
to do a video course on the top left
corner you see me and in the middle of
the screen you see David and David has
this ability of sitting there very
patiently and not moving at all while he
is waiting to control the truck so let's
see if we can have a chat with David hey
David can you hear us oh hello can you
hear me yeah we can hear you hey are you
online well yeah we're on a video call
right now so i think i'm online yeah
that's a good point hey we have a truck
here that we could use yeah truck I
thought we're gonna begin drawing a
drone now we had to cancel the drone
project okay can you help us with a
truck yeah absolutely okay so what are
you going to do so have the controls
pulled up over here on my phone okay so
if you hold up to the truck on your and
I can actually turn on and off the
lights so on off on off very cool can
you turn the front wheels left and right
yeah absolutely so right left right left
very cool can you spin the wheels a
little bit yeah so forward reverse for
river very cool I'm going to put it down
on the floor can you control it there a
little bit for us sure let me know when
you're ready okay we are ready but be
gentle very cool awesome thank you David
oh you're welcome very nice so next I
remember to bring the drum we will bring
the drone for you don't worry about that
but okay take care so thank
so what you have seen is magic basically
what we did was we have a web browser
running on a mobile device that can be
on a carrier's network that has the
ability to send real-time messages to
any web application out there or any
WebSocket client for that matter in our
case it's Java code running on the
Raspberry Pi if you're interested in how
this experience was created here for you
you can just Google here in the bottom
right corner you see you google for web
socket and popcorn popcorn is an awesome
media library and you can do these nice
experiences with it there's a blog post
that we just put out you can read all
the details now what do we do what do I
do when I am NOT here and having fun and
meeting a meeting nice people at meetups
there are many many challenges in the
real-time communication space that make
it really hard and challenging to build
and provide seamless experiences there's
a notion of firewalls and routers your
connection gets broken down because you
are in a tunnel maybe you need to scale
out to millions of users because you
become very successful suddenly these
are the kinds of problems that we are
trying to solve and we are very busy
solving a cuisine so if you want to
learn more about GU how GU enables web
web developers as well as creative
people here are a handful of links for
you that you can go to GU is going to
have or is having actually a beta
program and you're encouraged to sign up
to those and if you're interested in any
of the real time communication aspects
how you can bring this kind of power to
your web GL apps as well as to the
physical world you can visit the links
on the on the kissing side and last here
are here's the contact information for
us thank you very much
you